Hi, I’m Hannah Dickinson,
and this is Cheers to You,
where I’m kicking off
my first round of the weekend
by cheers-ing
all the people and stories
that encourage me to drink.
Cheers to you, Titanic 2,
for your plans
to set sail in 2022,
promising an authentic
Titanic experience.
By that time,
all the icebergs will be melted,
but people will be
fat enough to sink it.
(clears throat)
Cheers to you, David Schwimmer
look-alike,
for stealing beer
from a market.
The clerk didn’t notice
because HE WAS ON A BREAK!
Cheers to you,
Museum Of The Bible,
for admitting five of your most
famed artifacts are fake.
One of the them being the Bible.
I am a Christian.
Cheers to you, Snapchat,
for help registering
400,000 voters in the midterms.
I can’t wait for South Carolina
to elect Deez Nuts.
Cheers to you, John Mayer,
for sleeping with 500 women.
500 women
and zero allegations?!
That’s how you know
he made them cum.
Cheers to you, Sarah Silverman,
for letting Louis C.K.
masturbate in front of you.
I cannot wait for that remake
of A Star is Born.
And cheers to you, Fendi,
for putting out a shawl
that looks like a vagina.
Mine looks more like a knock-off
in any back room in Chinatown.
(off-screen laughing)
Well done, Hannah. Well done.
Another great episode
of Cheers to You.
And you can check out
our regular show
Every Damn Day on the Comedy
Central YouTube page,
where this week,
we did episodes about the best
Jordan Peele character,
a round-up of Florida Man news,
and we even did,
for Halloween,
a ghost peppered
candy challenge.
This is the reason
why this video gets dislikes -
is you walking on,
and making an ass of the show.
Cheers.